soprano merci nous accueillir ici au
zénith d'orléans pour la présentation de
votre album est vrai on le voit derrière
finalement il ya un petit peu de
montagne dans ce décor c'est un clin
d'oeil aux difficultés que vous avez
rencontrées dans la vie finalement le
nom de cet album
en fait oui c'est un peu nous c'était un
peu pour donner un peu aussi de la force
a beaucoup de jeunes qui qui se
reconnaissent dans mes textes leur dire
que voilà moi aussi j'ai traversé
beaucoup de trucs mais j'ai grimpé gmt
pour essayer d'arriver le plus haut
possible donc l'everest
la métaphore alors c'est un album qui
contient treize titres sm héros
évidemment du département des bouches du
rhône vous voulez rendre hommage
finalement à la ville qui vous a vu
grandir
ah ça c'est un peu le cliché que je
porte avec fierté c'est vrai que par
tous vermont paie le marseillais on
parle de l'om mon accent quand je parle
je suis cramé comme on dit je parle on
en entend c'est quelque chose qui
correspondent à ma musique et tous les
artistes qui vous accompagnent sont
marseillais excepté blacks
vous voulez montrer aussi finalement que
la ville de marseille foisonne de talent
bien sûr et encore ces patrouilles
il ya tellement d'artistes avec des
styles différents que ce soit dans
l'urbain ou ou dans la pop music et
c'est vrai que je voulais mettre ça dans
notre jeu vous êtes profondément attaché
à marseille tout cas représente la ville
en fête ben moi ensemble représente le
côté cosmopolite le causse et vivre
ensemble c'est un peu pour ça que mon
album précédent je l'avais appelé
cosmopolitan
c'est parce qu'une forme avait demandé
de de résumer en un mot marseille
j'avais sorti cosmo pro d'italie et
c'était un mot inventé
lors d'une interview c'est pour ça que
j'aime beaucoup mais un vrai toujours
influencé finalement par cette ville
pour créer de nouveaux univers de
nouveaux albums
d'ailleurs dans cet album j'ai lu votre
morceau préféré était en feu
qu'est ce que ça veut dire en fait pour
vous finalement être enfin ça veut dire
être bouillant comme on dit chez ou
encore marcelo sinon ça veut dire
vraiment être prêt à tout casser à à
être en être en forme toute la journée à
mettre l'ambiance lettres l'ambiance
avoir à bord sessions sont des foot pour
mettre l'ambiance assez sûr pour la
réalisation de cet album plusieurs
artistes ont influencé votre univers on
sentirait dans les différentes chansons
présentées notamment ben réel balavoine
coldplay ou encore plus surprenant
l'opéra on peut vous qualifier tout
simplement fait d'artistes on va dire
multi genres
ouais on peut mais on peut mettre cette
étiquette là parce que j'aime bien parce
que moi justement jeu ça fait des années
je me bats pour casser les clichés
moi je suis un artiste qui s'inspire de
plein de choses et je le mélange dans ma
musique et tous les jours essayer de de
faire des nouveaux styles des nouveaux
genres bon ça m'intéresse parce que ça
me permet de créer quelque chose de
nouveau et de créer mon univers à moi
est ce qu'il ya un râleur qui vous qui
vous a marqué qu'à marquer votre
carrière
un rapport moi j'aime beaucoup et eminem
j'ai beaucoup iam j'aime beaucoup
stromae parce que straumann a lancé un
appel pour vous ça rappeur ça il a
commencé avec du rap nous on a écouté le
premier morceau c'était un rappeur et
lui m'inspire beaucoup parce que
justement lui aussi des partis chercher
dans d'autres univers pour vous refaire
son univers et beaucoup de sujets de
société aussi vous vous interpelle dans
cet album vous évoquez notamment le
comportement de certaines filles en
quête d'identité mais aussi la perte
d'un proche malade c'est votre manière
finalement on va dire de les combattre
en fait ces sujets en fait ce qui est
bien avec le lacet plus mon côté rappeur
c'est vrai que d'autres
c'est bien de pouvoir la musique nous
permet d'extérioriser de un peu une
psychanalyse et c'est vrai que le fait
de pouvoir écrire ce qui se passe dans
l'actualité ce qui se passe dans ma tête
et dans mon cas ça me permet d'évacuer
et ça aide beaucoup de gens et ça permet
de ne pas fermer les yeux sur ce qui se
passe un peu autour de nous est donné de
la force ce qui filme ces moments
difficiles
très bien merci beaucoup se prononcent
d'avoir exercé avant la matinale 9h50 le
matin sur france 3 centre parce que j'ai
un bon petit déjeuner jerez merci
beaucoup